do something
in details and what I guess she can lead
to home yeah I'll do it so he came to
him
he's a chef you hate me it's why you
said they all about to kill me man I
said now you're following the footsteps
of prophets and messages
yeah so General Tower everyone was happy
with it yeah
you're happy with it it only said she I
don't do they agree details
that's why celebrities don't know to
speak in details you know there are
known to be people clarification people
have Clarity
yes and to implement that you have
studied
is
you know because otherwise how can we
know if I don't if I don't start the
book with the setup you're going to be
you can't be silently be care to be
celebrating and you there's different
amongst yourself how can I differentiate
if I don't study but if I'm sorry if I
do a study in seven minutes then I will
come to know